شكرا لك ميسون ايضا بالفعل فعلها اردوغان
اذا اعلنها رئيس اللجنه العليا للانتخابات
في تركيا الارقام النهائيه 52 بالمئه
لاردوغان مقابل
47.86
عن فرق حوالي اربع نقاط مئويه بين الرئيس
المنتهيه ولايته الذي اصبح الان رئيسا
لولايه ثالثه من خمس سنوات الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان مع منافسه
الرئاسيه كل جدار اوغلو عن المعارضه عن
تحالف يضم سته احزاب معارضه تركيا ولكن
هذه هي المره الاولى التي يتم الذهاب فيها
الى جوله اعاده الى جوله ثانيه من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه بعدما لم تحسم اذا
الجوله الاولى بين المرشحين الرئاسيين اذن
اردوغان فاز بهذه الجوله فاز بولايه
رئاسيه الثالثه في اخر التصريحات كما ذكرت
اذا رئيس اللجنه العليا للانتخابات اع فوز
اردوغان اذا بعد اتمام فرز كل الاصوات
زعيمه الحزب الجيد او الحزب الصالح التركي
هنئت اردوغان وهي من ضمن الاحزاب ضمن
الطاوله السداسيه والاحزاب المعارضه السته
خلف كمال في الجدار اوغلو من الاكشنال
زعيمه الحزب الصالح اذا هلئ رجب طيب
اردوغان على فوزه بجوله الاعاده في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لكنها قالت انها
ستواصل كذلك مسيرتها كمعارضه اكشنر اضافت
في تصريحات بان النتائج اظهرت ان هناك
درسا كبيرا يحتاج اردوغان الى تعلمه مشيره
الى انها تامل في ان يكون اردوغان رئيسا
لجميع الاتراك في طبعا في خضم هذه
الاحتفالات التي نتابعها معكم مشاهدينا
لانصار الرئيس التركي الفائز رجب طيب
اردوغان مباشره من انقره في هذه الصور
المباشره الان طبعا مع صدور هذه النت رغم
طبعا فوز اردوغان الليره التركيه انخفضت
الى
20.05 مقابل الدولار بعد اعلان فوز
اردوغان بالانتخابات اذا الليره تراجعت
مقابل الدولار مع اعلان الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردو في هذه الانتخابات الرئاسيه
وطبعا
هذا في انتظار طبعا المزيد من
الانعكاسات لهذا الفوز
وبالنظر الى ما سيقوم به الرئيس التركي من
القيام به من اجراءات في هذه الولايه
الرئاسيه الجديده الثالثه من جانبها
المرشح الرئاسي الخاسر كمال قال انه
سيواصل النضال على عكس توقعات بانه
سيستقيل من حزبه المرشح الرئاسي التركي
كمجدار اوغلو قال انه سيواصل قياده النضال
وذلك بعد ان اظهرت النتائج انه خسر ما قال
انه اكثر انتخابات غير عادله منذ سنوات في
مواجهه الرئيس الحالي رجب اردوغان في جدار
اوغلو اضافها انه حصل على نحو 47.9% من
الاصوات في جوله الاعاده قال في تصريحات
له من انقره ان النتائج اظهرت رغبه الناس
في تغيير الحكومه الاستبداديه كما وصفها
وقال انه حزين بسبب المشكلات التي
ستواجهها تركيا حسب تعبيره اذا الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان فاز مشاهدينا اذا
في هذه الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه وفقا
للنتائج التي اعلنها رئيس اللجنه العليا
للانتخابات في تركيا وهذا في انتصار يمدد
حكمه الى عقد ثالث في بلد
يعاني من ارتفاع معدلات التضخم وعواقب
زلزال مدمر مدمر مدن باكملها
اردوغان
سيكون اذا
رئيسا وسيكون امامه الكثير من التحديات
على الصعيدين المحلي والدولي وستكون
لنتائج هذه الانتخابات اثار تتجاوز
انقره بكثير حيث تقف تركيا على مفترق طرق
بين اوروبا واسيا وتلعب دورا رئيسيا في
حلف الشمال الاطلسي
النيتو الى المشاهدين كما تتابعون هذه
الحشود الكبيره
من المصوتين الذين من انصار الرئيس
اردوغان في انتظار الى الكلمه كلمه الفوز
الرسمي اذا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
بولايه رئاسيه ثالثه اذا من
خمس سنوات اذا الرئيس التركي
اذا سيتحدث بعد قليل امام انصاره من شرفه
القصر الرئاسي كما اعلن امام هذه الحشود
الغفيره التي تلوح بالاعلام التركيه وكذلك
اعلام حزب العداله والتنميه حزب الرئيس
الحاكم على العموم على الان مباشره من
اسطنبول مفردات العربيه راويه القاسم
راويه اذا فعلها اردوغان النتائج اغلقت
مراكز الفرز والنسبه حصل على
52% من الاصوات الصوره من عندك
اهلا بك صهيب يعني عمليات الفرز لم تتوقف
رغم انه النتيجه معروفه والاحتفالات تعم
مدن تركيا منذ تقريبا ساعتين او ثلاثه
يعني كما تشاهدون ورائي نسبه الفرز فرز
الصناديق وصلت الى
99.8
تقدم كبير الى حد مالي
مقابل
الحال نحن في مركز حزب العداله والتنميه
هنا في مدينه اسطنبول حيث الاحتفالات في
الخارج بانتظار كلمه الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان من مقر الرئاسه
بانقره لاول مره عاده الاحتفال او بكلمه
خطاب النصر يلقيه من الشرفه في مركز
العداله والتنميه هذا استثناء اليوم طبعا
هناك برقيات وصلت ان كان عبر تويتر او
اعلن عنها للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان من عده
رؤساء من رئيس الامارات من رئيس المجلس
الرئاسي الليبي من رئيس اقليم العراق من
الاتحاد العالمي لعلماء المسلمين العديد
من الدول حول العالم الان صهيب السؤال
الابرز هل فعلا نجح فقط اردوغان في كسب
هذه الجوله ام فشلت المعارضه واستغل بذلك
اردوغان نقاط ضعف نقاط ضعف المعارض بالفعل
بعد قليل مع ضيوفنا يعني لنحلل طبعا ابعاد
هذا الفوز بالفعل راويه وكما ذكرتي تقريبا
فرز غالبيه الاصوات يعني النسبه المتبقيه
لا يمكن ان تغير شيئا رياضيا يعني كذلك
اللافت
نعم راويه اردوغان قبل الكلمه التي
ننتظرها الان من العاصمه انقره كان تحدث
الى انصاره بالقرب من منزله الذين تجمعوا
حتى قبل اعلان النتيجه النهائيه مع تقدم
الفرز ماذا قال اردوغان اهم مقاله
طبعا شكر اردوغان كل الذين صوتوا لهم
ووعدهم وقال لهم دخلنا في قرن جديد اي
بحقبه جديده لم يعطي ملامح هذه الحاقبه
التي يمكن ان يعطي تفاصيل اكثر فيها في
الخطاب
الاتي تحدث ايضا وقال لكم
باي باي كمال وهذه كانت يعني احدى شعارات
كمال كيتشدار اوغلو طبعا كما نشاهد من
ورائي الجموع غفيره كبيره جدا تتجمهر امام
قصر الرئاسه
بانقره لا شك هناك عده تحديات صهيب
بانتظار الرئيس الحالي لمده خمسه سنوات
اخرى اهمها التحديات الاقتصاديه غلاء
المعيشه واعاده اعمار المناطق المنكوبه
التي يعني اعادت انتخاب الرئيس اردوغ نسبه
كبيره جدا ولكن نشير فقط الى نقطه مهمه
جدا عن اسطنبول حتى الان
كمال كليتش دار اوغلو يتقدم في مدينه
اسطنبول على اردوغان
51.7% مقابل
48.2% اما بانقره فالتقدم ايضا
كمال كليتش دار اوغلوبي 51.2
الجوله الاولى
المعارضه بالولايات او المدن الكبرى ولكن
رغم ذلك يخسر السباق امام اردوغان ارجو ان
تبقي معنا راويه نذهب الى مفرداتنا كذلك
الى اسطنبول ضحى الزهيري ضحى بانتظار كلمه
اردوغان انت كنت ترصدين قبل ساعات حتى قبل
اتمام عمليه الفرز احتفالات انصار اردوغان
اين انت الان بالتحديد والصوره كذلك عندك
صهيب في الحقيقه انا لم اسمع سؤالك يعني
بشكل جيد ولكن انا هنا امام مقر حزب
العداله والتنميه في اسطنبول حيث
الاحتفالات مستمره منذ الاعلان عن النتائج
الاوليه وحتى الان اوروبا ستستمر حتى
النتائج الرسميه لا يعلم
الذين نشاؤوا هنا
بفوزع الرئيس
الجوله الثانيه هذه الانتخابات الرئاسيه
سيدي يعرب احبكم هذه هي الاغنيه التي
غناها الرئيس التركي اردوغان من شرفه
منزليه هنا في اسطنبول في كل هؤلاء
الداعمين له والذين صوتوا له اليوم في هذه
الانتخابات وذا حدث كما قالت جميله راويه
منذ قليل لكن هنا كان وزير داخليه سليمان
صويلح وصل وتحدث مع الناس وقال نحتفل
لانكم اخذتم حقكم وبحقكم نحن في هذه
الانتخابات قال ايضا هذه انتخابات هذا بها
الشعب التركي باكمله بكل شرائحهم قال غدا
اليوم شديد يستحق جديده امل جديد قال بان
الرئيس التركي سيدني لم ننتخب رئيس تركيا
الى يقود العالم هكذا قال سليمان سويد
وزير
الداهريه هنا منذ قليل منذ ساعه تقريبا من
مقر حزب العداله
واذا كانت سيستقيل لكنه تحدث منذ قليل
وقال بانه لا يستقيل وبانه باقي وبانه
يعني
لم يعد يريد ان يكون شيطان
وانت الشعب ارسل رساله قويه والمعارضه
ارسلت رساله قويه في هذه الانتخابات شكرا
جزيلا لك نعود اليك تباعا ضحى كذلك انت في
اسطنبول لعلنا نذهب الى انقره ومشاهدينا
الصوره يعني على الجانب الاخر من الشاشه
بانتظار ظهور الرئيس الفائز رجب طيب
اردوغان ليلقي كلمه النصر رسميا امام هذه
الحشود الغفيره اذا من هناك اذا من انقره
معنا مراسل العربيه زيدانكلو زيدان اهلا
بك معنا اردوغان سيظهر بعد قليل ماذا
ننتظر
زيدان زيدان انقره هل تسمعني
طيب فقدنا الاتصال مع زيدان ربما نعود
اليه بعد قليل ولكن مشاهدينا هذه هي
الصوره خبر الساعه لهذه الليله فوز الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان بانتظاري ظهوره
اذن امام هذه الحشود الكبيره فعلا كما
تتابعون من انصار اردوغان الملايين الذين
صوتوا له في هذه الجوله غير المسبوقه لاول
مره في تاريخ تركيا الحديث يتم الذهاب الى
جوله اعاده بعدما لم تحسم لم تحسم السباق
من جوله اولى بين رجب طيب اردوغان وكمل
كلجدار اوغلو الرئيس التركي كان اعلن فوزه
بالانتخابات الرئاسيه
التركيه
وقال اردوغان مخاطبا انصره من ان الناخبين
منحوه مسؤوليه الحكم لسنوات خمس قادمه
واضاف مخاطبا حشدا مبتهجا من على متن
حافله في اسطنبول الفائز الوحيد هو تركيا
وكذلك طبعا قبل ان يتوجه انقره الى
العاصمه حيث سيلقي كلمه الفوز ويحيي انصره
من القصر الرئاسي اذا في العاصمه انقره
وطبعا بعد ذلك جرى اعلان النتائج من قبل
طبعا رئيس اللجنه العليا للانتخابات في
تركيا واعلن حصول اردوغان على 52 بالمئه
فاصل اربعه عشر
لصالح اردوغان مقابل
47.86 لكل جدار اوغلو اذا مشاهدينا وكذلك
توالت التهاني لاردوغان من قبل القاده
والملوك كما نتابع الان في العاجله الملك
سلمان والامير محمد بن سلمان يهنئان
الرئيس التركي اردوغان بمناسبه اعاده
انتخابه كان هناك الكثير كذلك من ردود
الفعل الدوليه المرحبه والمهنئه لاردوغان
بفوزه بولايه رئاسيه ث
اذا كما ذكرت هناك العديد اذا من التحديات
وكذلك التطلعات حول ما ستطبع هذه الولايه
الجديده من خمس سنوات لرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان وانعكاساتها داخليا وخارجيا على
العموم نبحث من اسطنبول مع المحلل السياسي
جواد جوك اهلا بك معنا ومعنا كذلك من
اسطنبول استاذ العلوم السياسيه الدكتور
سمير سمير صالحه مرحبا بكم معنا لعلي ابدا
مع ضيفي من اسطنبول سيد جواد
لاسالك بدايه زلزال مدمر ظروف اقتصاديه
صعبه كيف تمكن الرئيس اردوغان من الفوز
مره اخرى
تحيه لك ولضيفكم ولمشاهدينا الكرام طبعا
المعارضه لم تستفيد من هذه الازمه
والازمات التي مرت منها تركيا بشكل عام
مرشح
كمالك
مرشحا الذي كان يريد اردوغان ان يتنافس
معه في الانتخابات بالنتيجه كان يعرف انه
هو ليس في مستواه يعني
الشعب والناخبون رسالتهم كانت واضحه انهم
كانوا يريدون شخصيه اقوى من
كمالكوليستر
لكنه هو اصر على الترشح وهذه كانت بدايه
الهزيمه بصراحه كان الرجل عندها نوايا
حسنه لكنه لا تكفي بالنتيجه هناك في مقابل
رئيس اردوغان ملفين واجهه معا ملف
الاقتصاد الفاشل ملف الامني واستقرار
ومكافحه الارهاب
اردوغان غطت غطى المشاكل الاقتصاديه
بالملف الامني ومكافحه الارهاب والمواطنون
يعني صوته من اجل البقاء كما يقولون
البقاء الحكم في تركيا وعدم انهيار البلد
وغير ذلك بالنتيجه مبارك لشعب التركي
ولوطننا وبلدنا نعم نعم دكتور سمير صالحه
لماذا خسر كمال كلجد ولماذا فاز اردوغان
برايك
مساء الخير للجميع اولا خسر كمان برايي
لانه منذ البدايه كان يريد ان يخسر يعني
لم يكن عنده النيه في الدخول بمواجهه
حقيقيه باتجاه الربح بنى او اسس
استراتيجيه المعارضه
في الحملات الانتخابيه طريقه التعامل مع
مساله الاستعداد للمواجهه الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان بشكل خاطئ الاساس برايي لم يكن
متين لرفع هذه
الطاوله السداسيه اذا المشكله ليست فقط
كما الكوليسترو شخصي وربما صعوبه منافسته
لرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان المشكله هي منذ
البدايه في طريقه بناء المعارضه السداسيه
هذه المعارضه التي التقطت باتجاه التقاسم
المناصب والمصالح والنفوذ ومحاوله
مشهد يقدم مصالح الاحزاب الموجوده في
التكتل على حساب خيار الذهب وراء منافسه
حزب العداله والتنميه والرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان كيف انا وصلت الى هذا الاستنتاج
نلقي نظره خاطفه انا وانت سريعه جدا على
الانتخابات البرلمانيه كيف انتهت
الانتخابات كيف الطابله السداسيه احزاب
صغيره غير قويه لا تمثل واحد بالمئه من
مجموع الاصوات دخلت في البرلمان بهذا
الشكل والذي يتحمل مسؤوليه ذلك برايي هو
كمال كريستال اوغلو الذي يقول انه سيواصل
المسيحي لا اعرف اي مسيره وكيف سيواصل
يعني حزب العداله حزب الشعب الجمهوري الان
باختصار عليه ان يتحمل مسؤوليه اساسيه
باتجاه مسائله كمال كرد حول مجره نعم هذه
النقطه لافته الحقيقه استاذ جواد ما رايك
يعني كان كل التوقعات تقول انه كمالك سيت
رجل وينسحب من العمل السياسي وسيستقل من
حزب الشعب الجمهوري هذا الحزب العريق حزب
اتاتورك لكنه اعلن انه سيواصل النضال هل
تعتقد انه ما يزال هناك يعني لديه امكانيه
للعمل اكثر في في المشهد السياسي التركي
لا اتوقع ذلك
وانهزم امام الرايس اردوغان 11 مره
هناك في داخل حزب الشعب الجمهوري حماس
للاراده التغيير في داخل تركيا هم ايضا
لابد ان يتغيرون انفسهم هناك
استقطاب في داخل حزب الشعب الجمهوري موجود
هناك اكراد
علبيين من جهه
هناك اتراك العلمانيين المتشددين من جهه
اخرى التنافس صار واضحا جدا في داخل حزب
الشعب الجمهوري انا اظن انه لم يكن الوقت
الان لانه
المعارضه واجهت مع مفاجاه ولهذا السبب
يعني لا بد ان ينتظرون كم يوم ثم يبدا
الاستقالات واقالات ثم لانتخابات في داخل
الحزب لانه الحزب لابد المعارضه لابد ان
للمنافسه هناك تسعه انتخابات
السداسيه والتحالف السداسي للمعارضه لم
يكن متجانسا ولم يكن مبنيا يعني على
هزيمه اردوغان بشكل اساسي بل كان مبني على
التوافقات والمصالح لكل طرف وكان هناك
اصرار من المعارضه التركيه على الدفع او
من بعض الاحزاب المعارضه التركيه للدفع
باكرم امامو ولكن الخلافات يعني كانت
كبيره الى ان جرى الاتفاق المعروف
بان يترشح عن الاحزاب السته كمال السؤال
هنا هل لو كان اكرم امام اوغلو مرشحا
للمعارضه التركيه هل كان سيختلف في المشهد
يا ترى استاذ جواد
نعم يعني لو كان اي شخص غير كمال قد اشترى
لماذا ما كان يعرف احد لانه وجه جديد نفس
جديد بطاقه جديده الجيل الشباب
واراده التغيير واضح في الشعب التركي لكن
يريدون ان يكون هناك تغيير من المرشح من
انفسهم لكن كما قد اشتروا لاصر على ترشح
نفسه هناك كان الخطا بصراحه
اي شخص غير معروف لو كان خطاباته جيده
مناسبه بلغه مناسبه
كان يفوز بالسهوله كنا نعرف انه امر
المعارضه صعب جدا بسبب ترشح كمال بهذا
الشكل نعم دكتور سمير صالحه هل تتوافق مع
الاستاذ انه لو كان مرشح المعارضه اكرم
امام اوغلو لما تمكن اردوغان من الفوز
الاسم لا يكفي برايه يعني اختيار الشخص
الذي سينافس الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان كان
لابد ان يواكبه تنظيم حقيقي سياسي حزبي في
صفوف المعارضه التركيه التي قالت انها
توحدت فيما بينها
قبل نقاش الاسماء كان من المفترض نقاش
ايضا كيف
تتحرك قوى المعارضه التركيه ايضا مثال
بسيط في الجوله الاولى كما تتذكر كانت
تركيز على موضوع الداخل التركي الاقتصاد
الازمات الاقتصاديه وعلى موضوع التعامل مع
ارتدادات كارثات الزلزال وجدنا بعد نتائج
الجوله الاولى انه الارقام في مناطق
الزلزال كانت بشكل كبير فارق كبير لصالح
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان موضوع الاقتصاد لم
يكن له هذا التاثير لماذا لانه رئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان قطع الطريق باكرا
هذه الورقه من قبل المعارضه وسحبها مجددا
من يدها باتجاه الطاقه الكثير من الوهود
التغيير وذهب بهذا الاتجاه من خلال قرارات
عمليه في الاسابيع الاخيره ما الذي فعلته
المعامر المعارضه لترد هذه المره اعرف
انني اطيل تحركت به اتجاه طرح اسم بديل
ينقذها من ورطتها ما الذي فعلته كما تتذكر
ذهبت تستنتج بشخصيه حزبيه يمنيه قوميه
ياتي ويرفع معه شعار اللاجئ الوافد
تركيا من الخارج ومحاوله لعب هذا الملف
والمعارضه تبنت هذا الموقف هذا الطرح
والان هي تدفع ثمن برايي قبول خطه او
مشروع من هذا النوع ورطها اكثر فاكثر طيب
استاذ جواد هناك من يرى انه تفوق اردوغان
انه نجح على تسويق
نفسه
وعلى تسويق العداله والتنميه على انه ليس
حزبا اسلاميا سياسيا او حزبا دينيا بل هو
حزب علماني محافظ انه يعني هو
منتمي او متماهي مع نظام الحكم العلماني
او نموذج الدوله التركيه العلماني ولذلك
نجح في يعني اكتساب ثقه حتى من هم غير
محافظين او غير متدينين من العلمانيين
لانه قدم نموذجا جيدا في التسيير ما رايك
هل هذا هذا ما نجح فيه اردوغان وما انجحه
بالنهايه للفوز والاستمرار في حكم تركيا
منذ ان كان رئيس الوزراء في 2003 وهذه
الولايه الرئاسيه الثالثه الان
طبعا هو خطاباته كان اكثر ترجها الى
القوميه في الاغذنه الاخيره يعني كسب من
اصوات القوميين حتى يمكننا ان نقول كسب من
من قلعه القوميين في بعض المدن مثل ارزروم
مثل مدينه يوزجاتنا
المعروفه بالقوميه ايضا كسبتهم جميعا رئيس
اردوغان هذا الحزب صحيح انه معروف بانهم
اسلاميين لكن لا يطابقون شريعه الاسلاميه
ابدا هنا هناك كان مخاوف من قبل
العلمانيين انه علمانيين كانوا يقولون ان
هذا سياتي الى مثلا يتدخل في شؤون اسلوب
الحياه وغير ذلك هذا ليس صحيحا الرجل
بتمام المعنى علماني في اداره الدوله لكن
بصراحه يعني نجاحه كان مبنيا على القوميه
اكثر في
الخطابات القوميه صارت متطرفه يعني هذا
الذي يقلقنا هناك ثقافه الكراهيه بدات
بالنسبه الى المعارضه واستقطاب صار بين
اليوم كنتم تشاهدون عبر قناتكم الكريمه في
بث المباشر كانه احتفال
عيد
ومهرجان الناس بالهدوء وتناخبون جاؤوا
ورجعوا لكن كانوا يتهمون المعارضه بانهم
مثلا متورطين مع الارهاب كل من يسلط له
فهو يدعم الارهاب يعني تخلصنا الحمد لله
خلاص انت انتخابات وتخلصنا من هذه
الاتهامات لكن لم نشاهد في الامنه الاخيره
مثل هذه الاتهامات بالنتيجه لا يليق بساسه
ان يتهم المنافس له بانه ارهاب في عجاله
اسالك هذا السؤال هناك يعني مساله تبدو
مفارقه
يفوز في المدن الرئيسيه الكبرى في في
تركيا ان كان في الجوله الاولى او الجوله
الثانيه
بالذات انقره واسطنبول بالتحديد ولكن رغم
ذلك يخسر امام اردوغان ما تفسير هذا
هذا يعني انه المدن الرئيسيه في تركيا ما
زالت على حالها في اطار يعني عمليه
التغيير الحاصل ما زالت تتبنى
الموقف
المعارضه في هذه المدن الرئيسيه لكن هذه
المساله مرتبطه كما تعرف انت ايضا بموضوع
البلديات يعني الخدمات التي تقدمها
البلديات في هذه المدن الكبرى سيكون لها
تاثير كبير لذلك انا وانت في كلمه الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان يقول لقواعده الشعبيه قبل
قليل استعدوا لي اذار المقبل وهي رساله
مباشره انه نريد هذه المره استرداد مدينتي
اسطنبول وانقره براي المساله لن تكون صعبه
اطلاقا يعني مساله استبداد
لمدينتين لانه المعارضه برايي في المرحله
المقبله ستعاني من ازمات اكبر بكثير في
طرحها للمواقف اتيت على ذكر ما قاله
اردوغان مشاهدينا دعونا نذهب ونستمع الى
ما قاله الرئيس الفائز رجب طيب اردوغان في
اول تعليق له بعد فوزه بالانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه
[موسيقى]
اشكر كل الاعمال التي بذلها شعبنا وكلفنا
بحمل هذه المسؤوليه لاداره البلاد لمده
خمس سنوات مقبله اشكر شعبنا اذ اناط بنا
هذه المسؤوليه العظيمه ان شاء الله سنفعل
ما يجعلنا نليق بثقتكم وكما كنا جديرين
بثقتكم على مدار الواحد والعشرين عاما
الماضيه ماذا قلت لكم قبلا هذا الحب لا
ينتهي ليس الى يوم الاحد بل الى القبر
والممات
ولايه ثالثه لاردوغان اردوغان الذي هيمن
على السياسه التركيه لعقدين من الزمن
بدا حياته السياسيه كرئيس لبلديه اسطنبول
عام
1994 وفي عام 2001 اسس حزب العداله
والتنميه ليصل حزبه للسلطه في عام 2002
اما في 2003 اصبح رئيسا للحكومه
وفي 2012 اجرى مفاوضات سلام مع حزب العمال
الكردستاني انهارت الهدنه مع الحزب في عام
ليشتعل النزاع مره اخرى عام 2014 ثقب
كرئيسا للجمهوريه وفي 2017 اجرى تعديلات
دستوريه لاعتماد نظام الحكم الرئاسي عوضا
عن النظام البرلماني
اما مرشح المعارضه التركيه في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه كمالك فقال ان منافسه استفاد من
كافه امكانات الدوله واضافك الجدار في
خطاب له ان الانتخابات كانت اكثر انتخابات
غير عادله في السنوات الاخيره وشدد مرشح
المعارضه على انه سيواصل الكفاح داعيا
مناصريه الى مواصله النضال من اجل
الديمقراطيه واعرب كريشدار اوغلو عن حزنه
العميق تجاه الصعوبات التي تنتظر تركيا
على حد قوله
الامه اظهرت رغبتها في تغيير النظام
الاستبدادي رغم كل الضغوط التي تعرضنا لها
حزب الشعب الجمهوري سيواصل النضال على كل
الجبهات وسنكون الرواد لهذا النضال ومهما
قدمنا لهذه الدوله فلن يكون هذا كافيا
لكنني اشعر بالحزن بسبب ما ينتظر امتنا من
صعوبات لكننا سنواجهها وادعو 25 مليون
تركي ممن صوتوا لي ان يواصلوا نضالهم
هذا مشاهدينا اشير نحن معكم في هذه الساعه
بانتظار خروج الرئيس التركي الفائز في
الانتخابات رجب طيب اردوغان من العاصمه
التركيه انقره
اذا الان
ننتظر اذا الكلمه اذا للرئيس التركي
الفائز امام حشد كبير اذا من انصاره
الفرحين بهذا الفوز
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه في اخر
ردود الفعل المستشار الالماني هنا اردوغان
طبعا المانيا التي تستضيف عددا كبيرا من
الاتراك ومن المواطنين من اصول تركيا كذلك
المستشار الالماني
اردوغان بفوزه في الانتخابات الرئاسيه في
هذه الدوره الثانيه من الانتخابات مشيدا
بالعلاقات بين البلدين بوصفهما شريكين
وحليفين مقربين يقول المستشار الالماني
وقبل قليل كذلك هنا الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز وولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
كذلك رئيس التركي بفوزه بولايه الرئاسيه
ثالثه
طبعا نحن ما نزلنا ننتظر ايضا خروج الرئيس
اردوغان في انقره ليعلن رسميا ويحيي اذا
جماهيره الفرح بهذا الفوز طيب نعود الى
ضيوفنا استاذ جواد
قال تحدث عن صعوبات ستواجه تركيا بعد فوز
اردوغان بولايه ثالثه هل برايك يعني هو
مصير في هذه النقطه هل هناك صعوبات ماذا
يقصد المرشح كالجدار اوغلو المرشح الخاسر
بالصعوبات التي ستواجه اردوغان وستواجه
تركيا بفوز اردوغان
طبعا كل الخبراء يشيرون على مواجهه مشاكل
اقتصاديه
والتضخم
ارتفاع السعر عملات الاجنبيه مقابل الليره
يحذرون بقوه بالنسبه الى ما جرى في دعايه
الانتخابات كانت قناه الحكوميه التركيه
الان كنت انظر
48 ساعه نشروا من خطابات رئيس اردوغان
مقابل 42 دقيقه نشروا من من خطابات كمال
دعايه كانت غير عادله واستفادوا من
الامكانيات بشكل عام من جهه اخرى انه هناك
الكل يعرف انه
مشكله اللاجئ طبعا هذه المشكله سوف تستمر
لكن القضيه المهمه انه
السياسات الاقتصاديه الخاطئه سوف تاتي
سلبيات الى حاله
المعيشه في تركيا والصرف مصاريف الناس
المواطنون سوف يعانون يعني البنك التركي
بنوك بشكل عام قد اتوا بامارات انه هناك
مشاكل كبيره في اعطاء القرض الى مستقرضين
والمواطنين يعني الوضع ليس جيدا للايام
القادمه بالنسبه الى ملف الاقتصادي الفاشل
نعم نعم دكتور سمير صالح اسالك كذلك على
ما الذي سيطبع الفتره التاليه الان بعد
فوز اردوغان كيف ما الذي سيتغير في تركيا
وما الذي سيتغير في علاقات تركيا التي
يعني كانت مضطربه مع حلفائها كذلك في حلف
شمال الاطلسي كيف ينعكس هذا الفوز على
العلاقات مع الشرق الاوسط هل سيكون هناك
تسريع لملف المصالحه مع سوريا ام لا
سيتراجع مساله اعادتها ترحيل اللاجئين
السوريين كل هذه القضايا كيف ترى مستقبلها
في فوز اردوغان بولايه ثالثه
يعني طبعا الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان في
العام المنصرم بدا باعتماد سياسه خارجيه
جديده مغيره للسياسه التي كانت معتمده
ومتبع قبل سنوات سواء كان في الملف السوري
ملف العلاقات مع دول الجوار مع العالم
العربي المشكله الاساسيه هي العلاقه مع
الغرب يعني كيف ستكون في الاسابيع والاشهر
المقبله هذا سيكون مرتبط بطريقه التعامل
العواصم الغربيه مع نتيجه الانتخابات في
تركيا وقرار انفتاحها بشكل جديد على
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وحزب العداله
والتنميه اذا مشاعر الرئيس انه في تحول في
سياسات وموقف هذه العواصم في مسائل عالقه
بين الطرفين بينها مثلا الملف السوري
اظن انه ربما يبدا الرئيس ايضا بخطوه
جديده شعار التغيير مهم
داخل التركي ايضا يعني الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان اظن في الاسابيع القليله القادمه
سيفعل سياسه التغيير في ملفات ايضا اساسيه
في الاقتصاد في مسائل اجتماعيه عديده
تنتظره في المرحله المقبله المعارضه رفعت
شعار التغيير كما تتذكر الان فشلت اليوم
في الانتخابات هل سيكون هناك تغيير داخل
المعارضه نفسها هذه المره التغيير موجود
اذا
سيبقى بالنسبه لي المعارضه وبالنسبه
للحزب الحاكم كيف ستكون عمليه التغيير باي
اتجاه من الذي سيسرع برايه هو الذي سيفوز
في المرحله القادمه اكثر فاكثر نعم اشكرك
على هذه المشاركه معنا دكتور سمير صالحه
استاذ العلوم السياسيه كنت معنا من
اسطنبول اذا المشاهدين المستمرون معكم في
تغطيه خبر هذه الليله فوز الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان بولايه ثالثه من خمس
سنوات نحن بانتظار خروجه على هذه الجماهير
من على هذه المنصه في العاصمه التركيه
انقره
لاعلان فوزه رسميا طبعا بعد اعلان رئيس
اللجنه العليا للانتخابات في تركيا فوز
اردوغان بحصولها على 52.14 من الاصوات
مقابل
47.86 بالمئه لمنافسه بعد احصاء جميع
الاصوات تقريبا في جوله ثانيه من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه جوله غير مسبوقه في
تاريخ تركيا ايضا من الانتخابات ان يكون
هناك جوله ثانيه من هذه الانتخابات على
العموم اعود
واحاول ضيوفي اذا في انتظار كلمه اردوغان
الاستاذ جواد جيوك اعود اليك مره اخرى
فيما يتعلق
يعني الان بفوز اردوغان بهذه الولايه
تركيا الدوله التركيه تدخل قرنا جديدا في
ظل استمرار حكم اردوغان الذي هو عمليا حكم
تركيا لعشرين عاما يعني منذ ان كان رئيسا
للوزراء في 2003 والان يستمر في الخمس
سنوات القادمه برايك ما اهم السياسات التي
سينتهجها الرئيس اردوغان في بدايه هذا
القرن الجديد للدوله التركيه الحديثه
هو يعني
حكومه في تاريخ تركيا من بدء تاسيس
الجمهوريه التركيه
هناك عده مشاكل كما قلت مشكله الاقتصاد
مثلا
عندما هو
تحمل المسؤوليه في سنه 2002 اول ما جاء
الى الحكم كانت طيون تركيا 150 مليار
دولار الان في هذه السنه
450 مليار دولار يعني ثلاثه اضعاف مضاعفه
والحال ان الحكومات السابقه يعني 58 حكومه
جاءوا بناء معظم خمس مليار دولار هو صار
ضعفين على عاتق تركيا الملك عند هذه
النقطه يعني هناك من يحاجج ويقول لكن لكن
اردوغان في المقابل يعني وضع تركيا على
المسار الصحيح واحدث ازدهار اقتصاديا
بالنسبه للاتراك منذ وصوله الى السلطه رغم
صحيح ارتفاع المديونيه وارتفاعنا مستوى
التضخم ولكن تغير حال الاقتصاد التركي مع
وجوده في السلطه ام لا
طبعا نحن نقول نعم بعد هذه النتائج التي
راينا اليوم كالشعب التركي راضين عن ادائه
هذا الذي نفتهم
ولهذا السبب نحترم اذا كان هناك تضخم اكثر
على اي احد ان لا يشتكي منه هذا التضخم
المرتقب في الايام القادمه لكن بشكل عام
نعم هو بصراحه اتكلم عبر قناتكم الكريمه
في العقد الاول
كان ناجحا جدا في تطوير الاقتصادي وغير
ذلك في العقد الثاني بعد بدء ما احداث
ربيع العربي وغيره
تغيرت السياسات بشكل جذري التدخل في شؤون
العرب الداخليه ثم بناء الاقتصاد على
العقارات مثلا العقارات لم يفتح
مصانع وكانت دائما بيع باعوا كل الممتلكات
في تركيا بصراحه والى الان جاؤوا
بالاقتصاد بشكل اخر لكن لا بعد يوم امس
صرح بانه جاءنا اموال من الخليج
يقصد هو من قطر مثلا
ارتاحينا ارتاح البنك المركزي الى متى
بهذه السياسه الى متى لا تاتي بالجزء بحل
الجزر للمشاكل الاقتصاديه والخبراء
يعذرونه دائما انا اظن انه لو لا يقوم
بتحسين العلاقات مع الاتحاد الاوروبي سوف
نواجه مع مشاكل اقتصاديه الاكثر وايضا
تحسين العلاقات مع الامريكان ايضا تصفير
المشاكل مع جيراننا هذه القضيه مهمه جدا
هذه نقطه اخرى
هل برايك سيستمر النهج دعم حركات الاسلام
السياسي في العالم العربي
وما قيل كذلك على مساله العثمانيه الجديده
واعاده بعث العثمانيه الجديده
من خلال طبعا دعم هذه الحركات في الدول
العربيه التي كانت قبل 100 عام جزءا من
السلطه العثمانيه او من الدوله العثمانيه
لا اتوقع ذلك يعني الخطوات التي اتخذوا
قبل الانتخابات بداوا بالانفتاح بداوا
بتحسين العلاقات كم خسرنا من من قطع
العلاقات مع دوله مصر مثلا بسبب بعض
الجماعات المتطرفه هناك يعني
كان عليهم ان يرجحون مصلحه وطننا على
مصلحه الحزب ايديولوجيات الحزب كم خسرنا
خسارات اقتصاديه سياسيه وحتى العسكريه في
المنطقه في شرقي المتوسط لم يبقى لنا جارم
بدءا من سوريا الى مصر وغير ذلك ايضا
بالنسبه الى تحسين العلاقات مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه طبعا نحن نرحب بهذه
المبادرات خاصه كانت هناك تصريحات ايجابيه
جدا من قبل مسؤولين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والامارات كذلك نتمنى ان يختوا
خطوات سريعه وعمليه يعني اشق
[موسيقى]
اردوغان الاقتصاديه غير التقليديه التي
تسببت حسب المراقبين في ارتفاع معادلات
التضخم واجججت ازمه غلاء المعيشه
والانتقادات كذلك
للتكفل وبطء الاستجابه
بمتضرري الزلزال الا ان الاتراك كما نشاهد
باعداد كبيره جدا
صوتت لصالح اردوغان كيف فعلها اردوغان
برايك
تحياتي لك في البدايه استاذ صهيب الساده
المشاهدين نعم يعني هناك حقيقه في الفتره
الاخيره الماضيه كانت حاله من القلق لدى
الشارع التركي وخاصه فيما يتعلق بالمستقبل
كانت هناك شريحه كبيره تريد التغيير كنا
نتحدث عنها سابقا يعني قبل تقريبا يعني
فتره من الان ولكن هناك المعارضه التركيه
خلال
العشره الماضيه لم تقنع المواطن التركي
وخاصه فيما يتعلق بالاوضاع الاقتصاديه
فيما يتعلق بالمستقبل كنا نتحدث عن هناك
شريحه من الشباب خمسه سته مليون شاب كانوا
يريدون
التغيير وهناك ان يكون لهم مستقبل مختلف
تم هناك يعني التعويل على هذه المعارضه
لكن كانت منشغله بخلافاتها وبمشاكلها وحتى
ان البرامج التي تم طرحها كانت غير مقنعه
لذا انا تصور اعتقد الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان على الرغم من تراجع شعبيه حز
والتنميه هو استطاع من خلال يعني
الكاريزما من خلال البرمتيه من خلال
الخطاب المقنع
المؤثر ايضا في نفس الوقت للشارع التركي
هو ان يتصدقها هل تلمس تغيرا في الخطاب
بمعنى هل هناك
دعنا نقول تماهي مع مبادئ الدوله
العلمانيه وبالتالي
جذب لجميع الاطياف بغض النظر عن
الايديولوجيات فكان هناك هذه النتيجه التي
نتابعها اليوم
صحيح يعني رئيس رجب طيب اردوغان لاحظنا
يعني في الفتره الاخيره انا هناك دائما
كنا نتحدث عن المحافظين هنا في تركيا
والشريحه المحافظه نعم الرئيس اردوغان قبل
يومين قبل يعني حتى بالامس عفوا زار هناك
يعني بعض المناطق
كضريح عدنان مندريس ورئيس وزراء الاسبق
نجمتين وقام بالصلاه في مسجد ابو ايوب
الانصاري هذه لها دلالات فيما يتعلق
بالاسلام السياسي او بالمحافظين لكنه هو
متحالف ايضا مع القوميين وحتى ان سيلانو
جان هو دعمه رئيس رجب طيب اردوغان هو
تحاكى هو يعني كان يتحدث مع الجميع وخاصه
ان كان مع القوميين او حتى مع المحافظين
لكن في الفتره الاخيره الماضيه هو خسر كما
اشارتك في البدايه خسر شريحه كبيره من
المحافظين وسميت هنا بالمترددين لكن لا
استطاع ان يجزبهم خلال الفتره الاخيره من
خلال ستوب وهي المقنع في ان تركيا من دون
رجب طيب اردوغان او من دون حزبه سوف
يذهبون الى نفق مظلم وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بالامور الاقتصاديه نعم طيب معنا الان من
اسطنبول كذلك زاهد رئيس تحرير التركي اهلا
بك معنا سيد زاهد برايك ما اهم الاسباب
التي ادت الى فوز اردوغان بولايه ثالثه
بدايه التحيه الطيبه لك ولمتابعكم الكرام
ولضيفكم الكريم يعني هناك مجموعه اسباب
دعنا لنقل ابتداء في بالنسبه او السيد
اردوغان في الجوله الاولى استطاع حقيقه ان
يحسم معركته الانتخابيه البرلمانيه
وبالتالي وكان متقدما على خصمه باربع نقاط
تقريبا وبالتالي هذين العاملين ابتداء
واحد صفر دعنا نقول قبل المباراه بالنسبه
للسيد اردوغان هذه نقطه اساسيه مهمه
للغايه الامر الاخر السيد اردوغان يحكم
البلاد منذ عشرين عاما بما فيها من محاسن
ومساوئ بطبيعه الحال لكن من المؤكد ان
الشارع التركي
المنقسم سياسيا لم تقنعه خطاب المعارضه
السياسي ابتداء وانتهاء يمكن ان يقال ذلك
الامر الاخر بطبيعه الحال مرشح المعارضه
السيد كمال كريسترول صحيح انه كان مرشحا
توافقيا لكنه لم يكن توافقيا بالقدر
الكافي بمعنى انه لربما ربما اقول لو كان
هناك من مرشح اخر مثل اكرم من الموقع او
غيره من المرشحين او حتى الاستاذ زاهد
فيما يختلف اكرم امامو عن كمالك
ابتداء يختلف في الهويه السياسيه وفي
الخطاب السياسي يعني يمكن ان يقال انه
اكرم امام مغلو او منصوري واش هم اكثر
خطابا يمينيا بشكل عام ولا يمثلون ربما
الايديولوجيه التقليديه لحزب الشعب
الجمهوري كما يمثلها السيد كمال وبالتالي
انا اعتقد ان الخلافات ستكون كبيره في
المستقبل القريب في داخل حزب الشعب
الجمهوري وخاصه انهم مقبلون عن استحقاقات
داخل الحزب يعني المؤتمرات العامه للاحزاب
السياسيه عموما ستبدا بعد نحو شهر من
الانف ما في ذلك الحزب الحاكم بطبيعه
الحال
وبالتالي انا اعتقد ان هناك سيكون ما يمكن
تسميته بالمنافسه على قياده حزب الشعب
الجمهوري وكذلك قيادات الاحزاب المعارضه
الاخرى التي فشلت في الانتخابات وبالتالي
انا اعتقد انهم سيدخلون في صراع البيت
يعني صراع البيت من الداخل وذلك تحضيرا
نقل ايضا الاستحقاق قادم بعد تسعه اشهر
لانتخابات البلديه المحليه
هو الذي سيكون بطبيعه الحال بنكهه سياسيه
مختلفه ربما عن الواقع الذي عشناه في هذه
الانتخابات اعود اليك كذلك من الامور
اللافته في هذه الانتخابات الرئاسيه
التركيه العدد المهول للاطراك الذين
توجهوا للتصويت يعني ونسبه المشاركه
القياسيه برايك كيف يفسر هذا كيف يعني او
ما اسباب يعني تهافت الاتراك بالفعل على
المشاركه القويه في هذه الانتخابات
اعتقد الشعب التركي والاتراك كانوا هناك
امام خيارين الخيار الاول هو الاستمرار في
النهج الذي صار عليها الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان خلال العقدين الماضي واقصد النهج
هنا المحافظ وايضا هناك خيار اخر وهو خيار
الذي رسمه كمال كريشلار اوغلو وهو المتعلق
او
المتمثل في عوده العلمانيه والكماليه
وتكريز مبادئ كمال اتاتورك كل هذه هي كانت
حقيقه هناك نوع من التسابق ما بين هذين
المعسكرين لكن الرئيس رجب يعني طيب
اردوغان يعني من خلال يعني الفتره الاخيره
وخلاه الحملات الانتخابيه ومن خلال الخطاب
الذي كان هو اقل استقطابا من خطاب السيد
كمال كريستال اولو في العديد من القضايا
هو استطاع يعني ان يكسب يعني ود الشعب
التركي والشريحه التي كانت حقيقه هي
متردده ومنزعجه من سياسه الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان طيب سيد زايد سؤال الاخير
انعكاسات هذا الفوز ما الذي سيتغير
بالنسبه لي علاقات تركيا بالدول العربيه
من المؤكد انها ستتجه الى علاقه افضل خاصه
ان السيد اردوغان قال بصريح العباره قبل
يومين انه سيشكر من دعمه في هذه
الانتخابات وقال ساتوجه لهم بالشكر في
زيارات مباشره واعتقد ان زيارته الاولى
ستكون للمملكه العربيه السعوديه وسيبدا
وسيستل من المملكه العربيه السعوديه مرورا
بعدد من الدول الخليجيه الاخرى التي بادرت
في الوقوف بجانبه في ازمته الاقتصاديه من
جهه وتهنئته ايضا من جهه اخرى صحيح شكرا
جزيلا لك رئيس تحرير اندفندن تركي وكذلك
الكتب السياسي من اسطنبول مشاهدين شكرا
لكم انتم على كرم المشاهده اخبار الساعه
انتهت وخبر الليله فوز اردوغان شكرا على
المتابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات